soirée de gala à saint quentin en
yvelines autour du vélodrome le chantier
se poursuit jusqu'en 2013 mais déjà une
visite de chantier était organisée pour
quelques personnalités elle vient tout
juste de se tenir de se dérouler c'est
une soirée de gala anthony rech bonsoir
et vous suivez actuellement cette visite
la visite de chantier terminé comment ça
s'est déroulé ce soir oui nous venons
du chantier du vélodrome en compagnie
notamment de grégory baugé vice-champion
olympique d'oliver et julie volet fait
titrer cet été aux jeux en dtp
au cours de la visite nous avons pu
pénétrer au sein même du vélodrome tout
près des tribunes est la première
réaction de grégory baugé a enfin enfin
un pôle d'entraînement pour l'équipe de
france et de quoi faire évoluer les
ambitions tricolores pour les prochains
jeux déjà à rio qu'a donc ça c'était il
ya quelques instants à ce soir si vous
nous suivez en direct entre 18 et 19h
sur tv file en ce 9 octobre est ce que
cette visite a permis aussi d'en savoir
plus sur l'avancée du chantier on parle
donc d'une ouverture fin 2013 la date
est toujours maintenue et ce qu'on a
évoqué ce sujet
wilfrid évidemment la dap et plus ont
maintenu le chantier est dans les temps
j'ai pu voir déjà les tribunes qui font
déjà construites et monte autour d'eux
les phases de pipe in pipe dont la
particulière et le rat le bois le bois
rire de ribéry jeune architecte avec
l'idée de trouver un mois très
spécifiques et surtout très rapide pour
approcher les prochains record du monde
rend vite et la musique ronimo n'a plus
à les obtenir les aides par ailleurs au
niveau de la structure à côté du
vélodrome nous avons pu voir les pattes
qui accueillera l'équipe b un espace
unique en europe avec les couverts alors
la soirée là va se poursuivre la visite
est terminée c'est au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que les
festivités vont se poursuivre il ya des
grands noms du cyclisme qui vont être
présents qui vont être récompensés aussi
exactement il ferait des champions la
clôture' telle visite v go ribose
évidemment le champion du monde et
vice-champion olympique du qatar à la
julie bresset également et féline héros
membre de l'équipe de france répéter aux
jeux olympiques sera présent pour être
honoré autour des grands noms du pq
merci anthony je vais vous laisser
profiter de cette soirée justement est
dans notre édition de demain dès 18h
nous reviendrons largement sur sept et
dix sur cet événement avec de grands
noms du cyclisme français on referme
cette page sport pour se replonger dans
la politique et sur cette question du
cumul des mandats